hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and why is my [ __ ] cord
making all this noise maybe time for new
one I have no idea hey sorry about
yesterday I forgot it was Thursday I've
been promoting season four of f is for
family which you can stream now on
Netflix and I was also promoting the
king Staten Island
starring Pete Davidson Marissa Tomei
Steve Buscemi Dom Lombardo Z and a
zillion other mod Apatow zillion people
is now available to stream everywhere
except Netflix it's not on Netflix yet
but it's it's all those other places I
tweeted and instagrammed about it
alright
I am been on the tik-tok yet but I
totally forgot yesterday that yesterday
was was Thursday so by the time I
realized it was I'd already done Robins
podcast and I came home and I got the
two little ones to take care of now so
now I'm doing it now so I apologize for
it being late and I want to thank
everybody that's already starting to
watch f is for family in the king of
Staten Island saying all the nice things
that you're saying it's a fun day for me
all this hard work scene and get out
there and people actually enjoying it so
thank you very much and with that I'll
also be on the Joe Rogan podcast Joe
Rogan experience today it should be
posted today had a great time with him
smoked a cigar ol freckle smoked cigars
three days in a row three days in a row
the night before my birthday my birthday
and then I went in on Rogan and he had
some cigars so and now I'm shutting it
down again because I got to tell you bad
it takes a lot out of you get all [ __ ]
dehydrated super tired and all of that
[ __ ] so I don't think I'm gonna smoke
another one nor do I really even want to
until like August which makes me feel
good that I kind of I can dip in and dip
because it is a fun thing to do with a
great friend like Joe Rogan and then
it's also great to not do it because I'm
an old ancient dad here so I shouldn't
be doing that stuff so anyway it was
[ __ ] hilarious I went into Rogan and
he was talking about this [ __ ] going on
a Seattle and I had no idea what he was
talking about and you know because I
haven't been watching the news it's just
I don't [ __ ] screaming and yelling
like
malam I scream and yell it's almost like
watching a sporting event like no matter
how much I scream and yell and how much
I sit in my chair a certain way or try
to switch up the Mojo by jumping into
another seat I have no effect of what's
going on the outcome of this I I don't
know it's uh hoping cool heads will
prevail and something good will come
about it but at the end of the day I
think you know voting in that type of
[ __ ] hopefully I did look up a few
things well like what is defund the
police mean I'm like what the [ __ ]
you're talking about me who's gonna have
lawlessness out there and there was like
no it meant taking some of their burden
off of them before you get all freaked
out like I did cuz I was like that
that's ridiculous why would you do that
it means to reduce the demands placed on
police and shift funding to mental
health care housing and other social
programs and you know that makes sense
to me because I don't think it's fair
for everybody to just live their life
and ignore all the problems that we have
and then the cops have to deal with the
fallout of that so if funding mental
health care you know I think a lot of
people that are abusing drugs and that's
type of stuff I don't know we had a cop
write in one time from Canada was
talking about decriminalizing that and
treating it like a disease and then
people could like step forward and all
that type of stuff and just think of the
amount of people that maybe wouldn't die
from OD'ing because everybody else
they're doing drugs with leaves because
now you're part of like if this guy dies
you're somehow connected with his death
and can get go to you know jail time I
had a friend of mine die like that and
everybody [ __ ]
took off and just left them there
so yeah anything that's gonna anything
it's gonna ease tension I am definitely
four and I also think it's really
interesting how Seattle handles their
stuff where all those protesters went
down to the whatever the [ __ ] you call
it the head guy in charge his house
the mayor's house or something and they
just opened the doors and they let him
in there then that was kind of funny to
me because it's like alright so now
you're in the building so now what are
you gonna do but it's just that not I
don't know I don't I don't this [ __ ] is
so [ __ ] beyond anything that I
actually even understand I live my own
little life of watching old school
sports in that type of [ __ ] I have no
idea what's gonna I just hope people are
[ __ ] you know Otto always which I
really do believe something positive is
going to come from this I hope before
the the people with the money do what
they always do so let's get back to my
little life here my little life
downloaded some cool new music a friend
of mine let me know about this artist
Gabriella Wilson I'm an old guy so I'm
late to the party here she goes by her
age period a period our period I
downloaded both of I was so blown away
by the first song I heard and I just
started you know when on iTunes checked
it out I downloaded both albums [ __ ]
outstanding incredible check that out if
you get a chance to and I've been
dealing with my daughter she's in this
new phase super control freak like bossy
[ __ ] you know and I know you're not
supposed to say bossy remember the band
the bossy thing say call a little girl
bossy and she starts to avoid leadership
roles because she's afraid of being seen
as unlikable that's a very extremely
simplistic [ __ ] I don't know is that
all it is how about not creating a
maniacal oppressive lunatic I mean I
love my daughter
okay I'm not trashing her obviously but
I'm sitting there playing with and she's
just like no doubt that you have to sit
there no
come on dad you have to say this you say
it's like dude this isn't playing this
isn't like we're not we're both not
having fun right now you're just telling
me what to do and yelling at me telling
me that I'm in pretending I'm doing it
wrong
yeah that's being bossy and you
shouldn't be like that and that has
nothing to do with being a leader I
don't think you know like if I this [ __ ]
I've been saying about Trump it's like
when kovat happened your first reaction
to say well this came from China and
make sure the blame was put where it was
is to me that as a as a follower that
shows like weakness you know to have
these protesters coming up to the fence
and then you go and down into the bunker
that's not what you got to step up when
you're a leader and I don't think that I
don't know I know it's just it's just a
weird [ __ ] time it's just a weird
time where the cork is off the bottle on
a lot of [ __ ] so it's gonna be a highly
emotional [ __ ] time and then it's
gonna settle down and I think that
people are gonna agree that right but
you know there's a reason the word bossy
exists some of that [ __ ] you just you
[ __ ] attic waiting until like a
goddamn word like if you don't call
somebody a word then all of a sudden
they're gonna be a [ __ ] president or
something like that I mean none of it
makes any sense all right if this dope
can be [ __ ] President it really I
mean and contingent can like continue to
make sense to people and I'm not
[ __ ] on Republicans I'm just saying
this [ __ ] guy then III don't know
it's it's beyond me I [ __ ] hate this
time in history right now with this is I
think nothing is fun nothing is funny
I'm not on stand-up I'm [ __ ] talking
into myself I got nothing to [ __ ]
talk about every day there's something
else some [ __ ] idiot drives a car
into a [ __ ] crowd and then shoot
somebody i mean jesus [ __ ] christ and
then meanwhile there's this [ __ ]
pandemic going on and all these [ __ ]
[ __ ] a bump and fists out there
spiking this [ __ ] while they're there
trying to solve this [ __ ] problem
there then they're gonna make a bunch of
old people die or small businesses go
out of [ __ ] business because people
are gonna continue to get sick because
now there's a spike in this [ __ ] so i
don't know what the [ __ ] i have no idea
but i'll tell ya it's [ __ ] ridiculous
and they mean why we're fighting a
couple of you know never-ending goddamn
war is that a [ __ ] cost us a ton of
money but other than that it's a
beautiful day out there today and i'm
gonna play one morning in maine with my
daughter you know and if she gets too
[ __ ] bossy i'm gonna tell her that
you know i don't say bossy but i just
you know i think that's just a white
woman thing you know they're sort of
above criticism which is why i'm loving
that
okay karen thing and a lot of the
reactions to white women about that like
wait you're in sauce but we're always
the victims we don't have any privilege
our white husbands take all of our
privilege that [ __ ] narrative the
put-upon blonde white woman it's one of
my favorite [ __ ] that in the the an
indignant thief is my other favorite
characters right now like I'm insulted
by that question you know when you
[ __ ] call him out dude what the [ __ ]
is with this goddamn [ __ ] TV I got
this [ __ ] remote control where it's
like it either shuts off the box or at
shut or and then turns on the TV or the
other way around and I can't figure out
this [ __ ] Rubik's Cube [ __ ] either
that or I'm saying too much crazy [ __ ]
on my podcast and then [ __ ] some
[ __ ] turning it on yeah bill I think
that that's what it is cuz you're that
you're that important with you [ __ ]
horseshit okay so now that's often and
the [ __ ] TV comes on so there's got
to be a [ __ ] TV button TV off now
thing has a red light now long I bet
this thing's gonna be like humming now
right why did I buy a pencil sharpener
what the [ __ ] why did I have a pencil
sharpener what was I oh I know why I was
[ __ ] right now drum charts you know
and all of a sudden I bought an
old-school one and I'm like there's no
place to clamp it on to any more [ __ ]
outside of the house so then I got an
electric one you know like I'm some
accountant in April in 1958 finishing
everybody's goddamn taxes or the end of
March anyway so I just been watching a
bunch of [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I've had it
guys I need to go back I got to start
doing [ __ ] stand-up I am come I am
officially out of [ __ ] to talk about I
don't give a [ __ ] I just at this point
am i nuts like [ __ ] it I guess kovat is
here to stay and either live or you
[ __ ] die the only thing is though is
these [ __ ] hospitals now they got
like gave you two thousand [ __ ]
patients all of a sudden two thousand
[ __ ] patients come in on the same
goddamn day I mean I gotta start getting
guests on this thing we could just sit
here and just talk about nothing you
know so like what have you been doing
what is what is your workout been
throughout all of this by the way thank
you for the birthday wishes on Wednesday
I turned 50 to pick up
I had a great birthday I had a perfect
birthday I had a I had a I had a root
beer float and I smoked a cigar alright
and you can call me simple you can call
me dick and call me under the [ __ ] you
want I mean that's it's all I need you
know it's goddamn people at this point
you know when you get to a certain point
that they really should be just stop
buying somebody stuff I don't need any
[ __ ] stuff you know something I also
I realize if you've noticed me on these
zoom conversations I have like five
t-shirts that I wear and that's it I got
a blue one I got a green one I got this
I sling one I got a Queens of the Stone
Age t-shirt and I have a [ __ ] Austin
City Limits t-shirt and that's pretty
much it
so I really only need like five [ __ ]
t-shirts you know I guess when I'm not
working I don't need any of my
button-down shirts Oh Billy [ __ ] Bozo
the Clown when I go on stage I'm really
realizing how all of this [ __ ] that I
have I don't even [ __ ] need this
isn't anything what it is is I I need to
[ __ ] go on a drive
I've been nomadic my entire adult life
being on the [ __ ] road and I need to
I need to [ __ ] I think I mean I I
can't believe I need to go to a [ __ ]
airport need to go to airport and I need
to go into a strip mall
I didn't II just stand on stage and I'm
gonna dump all this [ __ ] out of me yeah
I got I get it
give it up to the protesters man I mean
this is just like unprecedent weeks of
this [ __ ] and then not letting up this
is this is gonna change things I think
in a good way but in the meantime I
would love to go on stage and tell some
[ __ ] jokes to somebody anybody all
right and then this is what I'd love to
uh this guy says Pete hagseth
on Seattle protest zone we're getting a
scary glimpse into what the leftist one
everything has to be [ __ ] labeled
because once he's if he just said what
these people are doing is [ __ ] scary
you could be so much more open-minded
when you read it or you wouldn't have
your mind already made up with the
people like oh these liberal snowflakes
let's read a little bit of this see what
this [ __ ] guy has to say Oh Fox News
this is a no this is a they are as
open-minded as see it and see as
protesters in Seattle continue to claim
their own territory Fox and Friends
weekend doesn't that sound fun Fox and
Friends sounds like a kid show host Pete
hagseth said on Friday that leftist
ideas such as defunding the police
dissolving the southern border and
revoking the sec amendment will not work
yeah you what is this what is dissolving
the southern border by the way who are
these [ __ ] people making me like
how to run the country well what is your
would you major in political science the
question is do you need to set do you
send in troops do you say hey this isn't
going to happen anymore or do you let
Seattle sort of implode on itself it's a
scary glimpse into the minds of leftists
right now
yeah people on the extreme left have
lost their [ __ ] minds same as the
extreme right and it'd be nice if people
at Fox News would occasionally call out
extremists on the right and CNN could
call out extremists on the left they
just don't [ __ ] do it oh god there's
got to be some other [ __ ] news is
there any other Trump says he's fine
with pushback from Pentagon leaders in
reversal Starbucks will allow employees
to wear black lives matter t-shirts
people you have to understand the the
quagmire that Starbucks is in alright
they live by the bottom line okay
in racists either hardcore or borderline
buy their coffee so all they're trying
to do is just straddle the [ __ ] line
alright we'll say that we care but we
won't in a clothing way state that we
give a [ __ ] so I can sell a chai latte
to an African American or a [ __ ] Klan
member because at the end of the day
people a corporation does not give a
[ __ ] where their money comes from okay
because you see they say we're not doing
that and then all of a sudden today
they're gonna do it why are they gonna
do it cuz enough money said that's
[ __ ] up okay so they they don't they
don't give a [ __ ] now are they guilty or
they just playing the game the way that
it's [ __ ] set up I mean that's
[ __ ] disturbing the way that you can
just you know there was another guy who
got removed some CrossFit guy and I'll
tell you it nobody is going to enjoy the
cross
community imploding like I am I mean
this has nothing to do with CrossFit it
has everything to do with the fact that
I just hate watching people running down
the street when I'm [ __ ] sitting
there trying to eat you know eggs
over-easy I some [ __ ] idiot running
down the street with the [ __ ] coffee
table lifting it up and down screaming
and yelling like they're in the [ __ ]
military and I'm on a base CrossFit what
a collection of [ __ ] self-involved
douchebags and I love that as they
thought it was such a positive
environment that their Fuhrer
turned out to be a [ __ ] [ __ ] this
has nothing to do with CrossFit has to
do with the [ __ ] I have cabin fever and
I haven't been able to do what I love
which is stand up it's finally hitting
me it's after I said I didn't care after
I said it didn't bother me after I said
he didn't miss it that was me just
denying my [ __ ] feelings and now it's
all coming to the surface all right
let's see here
what do we got here that's great
disappointed some crossfitter who looks
like she could throw me through a
[ __ ] goddamn side of a battleship
said she was disappointed with
CrossFit's charges as former CEO still
owns the company What did he say I
wouldn't know what he said cross it Greg
Glassman
Greg Glassman that just sounds like
somebody in your high school class says
he's there right he's just background
Greg Glassman all right George Floyd
scandal is a lesson in corporate
compliance and how not to set a tone
from the top yeah but exactly but here's
the [ __ ] thing about that all this is
teaching people is to shut the [ __ ] up
sorry my voice just cracking in that's
all it's teaching them it's not it's not
you're not changing their hearts
CrossFit CEO Greg Glassman got
Glassman's not quote not racist tweet
about George Floyd and the coronavirus
in CrossFit subsequent lack of action is
parable is a parabola a parable I don't
know of corporate
compliance and ethics screw-up of
massive proportion it is proof that a
damaged corporate culture has real cost
yeah you could also equate that to the
individual
well we always make choices for
ourselves first
over the weekend Glassman responded to a
tweet by the Institute of Health metrics
and evaluation about the link between
public health and racism by writing it's
Floyd 19 referring to the man who was
killed by white officers in The Cove in
nineteen and emic yes we can figure that
out he then went on to explain your
failed model quarantined us and now
you're going to model a solution to
racism he lost a bunch of money in his
gyms that's what happened so he got all
into his feels it's like first she's a
silly this guy he doesn't give a [ __ ]
have everybody come down here and sweat
all over each other I don't give give me
this is this is this is a tale as old as
time itself you hit this guy in his
wallet look at this guy he's like I
don't know how [ __ ] old he is he
still has a hat on backwards talking to
young people oh yeah this guy yeah he's
gonna make a bunch of [ __ ] snap
judgments on this guy George Floyd's
brutal murder sparked riots nationally
quarantine alone is quote accompanied in
every age and under all political
regimes by an undercut of suspicion
distrust and riots thanks wait that's
what he wrote your failed model
quarantined us and now you're going to
model a solution well now who's he
talking about
and the quarantine model failed people
because people didn't comply with it the
reality is is if everybody stayed home
it didn't [ __ ] breathe on each other
this thing would have burned out by
nothing my nuts but then there was a
bunch of people being like this was
designed to take Trump down Trump came
up with this
ba-ba-ba-ba you know you thickeners
America I can walk around into a bar if
I want to write a bunch of people with
no [ __ ] background in in any sort of
fighting a [ __ ] pandemic a bunch of
people with no [ __ ] a bunch of people
like me we don't even [ __ ] they're
talking about went out and [ __ ] that
whole thing up so I don't know who he's
yelling at oh my god is it me is this
podcast the most mind-numbingly boring
thing you've ever heard in your life
because it is for me I am so [ __ ]
sick of all of this [ __ ] [ __ ] i I'm
sick of it
I'm [ __ ] sick of it and I can't
[ __ ] deal this is why I don't go on I
don't this is why stay off the internet
I am so [ __ ] sick of everybody's
[ __ ] goddamn [ __ ] opinions about
[ __ ] and not looking at themselves and
how the [ __ ] they're contributing to
[ __ ] and I'm just sick of not having
[ __ ] happy topics we're in the
[ __ ] news is there just something
silly and ridiculous that I can [ __ ]
make fun of because I never I never had
a heavy podcast I never wanted to have
one all right and CrossFit guy Glassman
ten athletes banned from CrossFit Games
for steroids Jesus part of the [ __ ]
Internet am i on all right man seriously
injured in West Seattle shooting that's
not fun
two dead in South Seattle shooting woman
killed man injured in North Seattle
shooting Seattle police shoe this is all
Seattle Seattle Seattle so yeah that's
like the early 90s again after fatal
shooting Seattle Seattle am I in the
wrong okay world here we go
let's get to some good news let's get to
the world news faded away into a dark
nightmare North Korea says diplomacy
with Trump has failed I thought him and
that guy will boys u.s. Iraq talks
promise US troop withdrawal falls short
of timeline alright well good good see
we're gradually pulling out of there
international crime court condemns us
sanction order that sounds like fun
Arab envoy warns Israelis that annex
annex add them to dump for this page
Boris Johnson says attacking statues is
lying about our history visit well isn't
that finally an honest response from
people that were caught under the tires
are those people it's not like books
about those people the statues you
really don't need a [ __ ] statue do
your statues [ __ ] a statue was as
dumb as a [ __ ] headstone on a grave I
never understood that it's right you're
dead could put them in the ground and
help them enrich the [ __ ] soil we're
all part of nature let's do this right
put them in the ground
butt-ass naked no shoes unless they're
biodegradable
all right the woman behind France is
black lives Frances black lives matter
movement wants a race blind Society to
recognize its racism new Korona cases
see Beijing closed to food markets
scrapped plan to let some kids resume
school - this is just this is [ __ ]
nuts let's let's Google up with some
sports sports news how about that what
do we got here Sports News significant
number of players disappointed about not
having a vote oh my god
NCAA Committee recommends six weeks
calendar to start 2020 college football
[Music]
Wow Wow
latest sports news okay here we go
something fun guys if I didn't have a
bunch of [ __ ] I had to go [ __ ] do I
would literally scrap this [ __ ]
podcast Oh Alex Cora Astro sign stealing
scandal wasn't just two-man job no [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah I know and you know what that
mobbed-up NBA ref wasn't just by himself
all right since the Boston Red Sox fired
him for his role in the Houston Astros
electronic sign stealing scheme from
2017 former manager Alex Cora has kept a
low profile now he wants to clear a few
things up this is why Epstein got
whacked all right I have read many
things that are true and many others
that are not Cora told ESPN out of this
whole process press process if there's
one thing that I can completely reject
and disagree with his people within the
Astros organization sig singling me out
particularly fired and suspend fired and
suspend a general manager judd lund now
is if I were the sole mastermind the
commissioners report sort of explained
in its own way what happened but the
Astros players have spoken up and
refuted any allegations that I was
solely responsible if there is one thing
I'm absolutely sure of it is that it was
not a two-man show we all did it and let
me be very clear that I am NOT denying
my responsibility because we are all
responsible yeah I mean if you owned a
[ __ ] baseball team okay and then all
of a sudden somebody was drilling a hole
in the [ __ ] the wall out and out in
the [ __ ] center field you wouldn't
notice you wouldn't have somebody
walking up and going what the [ __ ] is
going on here hey yeah what are you
gonna do what are you gonna do
you know when there's money and [ __ ]
and cocaine at the end of the rainbow
like people are gonna do [ __ ]
once allegations of science stealing
were published by the athletic in
November Major League Baseball launched
an investigation with leads to January
firings in a one-year suspension of lund
now and former Astros manager AJ Hinch
Cora the bench coach of the 2007 World
Series champion took the Red Sox job
that offseason and won the world's de
the next year the Red Sox fired court
two days after Leno and Hinch were let
go
they weren't let go they got a one-year
suspension now you watch this all the
baseball is [ __ ] outraged these guys
will get jobs again MLB report found an
operation far more limited in scope and
impact in Boston and the penalties were
much lighter uh oh really
that's surprising the two-man show or
they just didn't want to seem like they
always do that like it was just one
[ __ ] year the two-man show quota
referred to was him and former player
Carlos Beltran who was hired and fired
by New York Mets this offseason for his
role in the scandal out of respect for
the investigation I decided to stay out
of the spotlight talking about it wasn't
going to change anything Cora told ESPN
I deserved my suspension and I'm paying
price for my action and I am not proud
of what happened well you look pretty
excited when you won the thing we made
we made a mistake as a group the entire
Astros team what happened was something
that if you asked anyone involved no one
was is proud of it we're all at fault
everybody we're all of responsible
everyone who was part of the team oh my
god Emma submits the after-party must
have been so [ __ ] gross as you
sitting there [ __ ] hugging on each
other we did it we did it and in the
back of your head you have to know him
somebody's got to be like dude this is
[ __ ] this is ridiculous right [ __ ]
are we celebrating here
I'll look at how I clicked on some
clickbait celebrities we forgot we're
married did we forget has anybody had
the nerve to watch that video I saw this
I saw a quick little clip of celebrities
owning up to their own racism and what
I'm gonna guess is this going to be a
lot of white women crying the genius the
genius of crime is you can own up to
what you did while getting comfort you
know I think if you're a woman as a guy
people just make funnier or maybe none
of them know men have ever had the
courage to try to [ __ ] you know use
that emotion
alright LegalZoom it's a whole new world
out there everybody we're all faced with
new challenges if you need legal help to
overcome some of yours
that's where LegalZoom fits in maybe
you've been wondering about the best way
to protect your family or maybe you're
thinking about starting a business but
you don't know the best way to do it
don't let legal questions hold you back
Legal Zoom has been dedicated to helping
you with the right solution for more
than 19 years if you're looking to
protect your family with a will or
living trusts or are you thinking about
the right way to start a business with a
DBA LLC nonprofit or MOA Legal Zoom
legal zooms got you covered it's easy to
get started online why am I reading this
like [ __ ] Christopher Walken cadance
it's easy to get started online and if
your if you need guidance and their
networks of attorney come on and if you
need guidance their network of attorneys
can provide advice to ensure you make to
ensure you make the right choices and
since Legal Zoom isn't a law firm you
won't have to leave your home and you
won't get charged by the hour visit
legalzoom.com today to take care of some
important things you need to get done
and that's legalzoom.com Legal Zoom
where life meets legal you know part of
the Rogan
guess we were talking about pubic hair
it was once something people were proud
of and then gradually trimmed and then
tried to eliminate and I can't believe
that we didn't even [ __ ] hit upon
like there's got to be there's got to be
something out there in the internet
webosphere about all the covet bushes
out there at this point all these poor
women who can't go in and get [ __ ]
waxed you know tend to the Beehive down
there it's got to be a tough thing oh
for God's sakes my wife's texted me here
by the way how do you shut off the
[ __ ] thing other than hitting mute
but then you can't watch videos of this
[ __ ] thing going Bing every time you
get a every time you get a [ __ ] text
message oh look at that nice see just
watch the king of Staten Island you
[ __ ] crushed it got me hyped for our
thing
oh good deal I mean know who that is
because I'm still getting text messages
from [ __ ] just numbers you know what
that means I think no you know what Mike
my my my computer will only accept text
messages from iPhones it won't take him
from from other people with their
androids alright I gotta have these
things here alright babe okay alright
let's leave all right I gotta go take
care of the baby he's awesome he's
looking around he hears noises and he's
turning his head towards it what else
he's really strong and he's so cute and
I love him to death and the greatest
thing ever when I was was I was holding
my son and then my lovely daughter came
up and gave him a kiss and I had my arm
around my daughter and I was holding my
son and I got to tell you man that's
what it's all about and I want to thank
my lovely wife for everything she has
gone through in both pregnancies and I
wanted to a I want to apologize to her
for suggesting we have a third right
after she just had a c-section I really
want to apologize to her for that like
this is awesome
come on let's do one more
all right that is that is it I'm gonna
go play t-ball with my lovely daughter
I'm sorry this one was really this this
quarantine thing is [ __ ] getting to
me like it's getting everybody else I
try to put on a brave face for you for a
long time and I'm just showing that
maybe I'm a little human and it's really
bothering me I hate everything that's
going on right now I hope people come
together for a better world
I really do I hope people you know drug
addicts get treated like you know they
have an illness I think there's
something to be said about you know
controlling people and then there's also
letting people hearing people's voices
and I have empathy for everybody
involved that's what I have okay
I don't think it's fair to make it out
that all cops are like those [ __ ]
murderous [ __ ] in Minneapolis we
need to figure out a way to [ __ ] get
rid of those people on the force and you
know I also think all the whole black
lives matter thing and people finally
white people finally listening and
joining it and trying to make it change
I think this is all going to come to a
good place we're just in the tough part
right here at the growing pains of this
but uh I'm confident that it's going to
get to someplace better and the cove it
thinks the only thing that's bumming me
out that it's starting to spike again
and all these [ __ ] overworked doctors
and nurses are not going to see a bunch
more patients please don't be a selfish
[ __ ] okay you know as we try to like get
back to some sort of a normal life just
try to you know I don't know wanted this
but drogon said something great on his
podcast as he always does whether
they're just talking about how to avoid
it they're not talking about your immune
system in that type of [ __ ] so I don't
know listen to his podcast don't listen
to me cuz I'm a dummy that's it
that is the podcast go [ __ ] yourselves
have a great weekend you [ __ ] and I
will see you on Monday and I will I
promise you guys on Monday I'm gonna do
a bunch of research on the Internet and
I will look for some silly [ __ ] for me
to talk about because I don't want to be
just another thing that's out there
talking about what everybody already
knows I would like to be an oasis
well you can put your brain on pause for
a second and listen to my dumb stupid
[ __ ] thoughts about praying mantises
eating hummingbirds you know and dumb
[ __ ] like that
alright that's it god bless you and god
bless everybody out there alright [ __ ]
you sorry I can never hang hey what's
going on it's Bill burr and it's the
Monday morning podcast from June 11th
2012 2012 which I am actually recording
on Sunday June 10th which is my birthday
my birthday it's your birthday you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
another years gone you're still sitting
there in that [ __ ] place you don't
wanna be so eat some cake blow out the
candles but not in that order or else
you will burn your [ __ ] mouth mouth
MOU F F mouth um hate it did Manny
Pacquiao lose last night is that what I
heard somebody left me a message that he
[ __ ] he lost
that's unbelievable I can't believe that
little roided-up guy couldn't do it I
think everything is [ __ ] fixed don't
listen to me I don't think it's possible
for a guy comes in at 109 pounds
to put on 40 pounds of muscle not lose
any speed or any power get actually okay
I've seen that show it's called the
[ __ ] bionic man that's the only thing
that was missing that's what they should
have shown in the beginning of all
Pacquiao fights was him crashing some
experimental aircraft like John Denver
except he doesn't die you know and John
Denver would have died wouldn't have
died he would have lived if he wasn't
wearing those stupid glasses that's what
did him in those little granny glasses
like you sat around making cookies in a
tree you know like those Keebler Elf
that's what killed him a lot of people
don't know that they thought it was
massive head trauma and an carnage to
his ribcage area with them with the
vials there behind it you know the
floating rib that they gave over to that
[ __ ] [ __ ] who couldn't stop eating
the apples right wasn't that it wasn't
massive head trauma it was very minimal
very specific he slammed his head off
the experimental dashboard and his
mainstream glasses then shot it through
his eyes into his brainstem Rocky
Mountain High Colorado and then he died
and that's what happened everybody
blamed the aircraft you know but
everybody who actually goes out and gets
a pilot's license I believe on the first
day they tell him not to wear those
glasses much last time you got on a
plane and you saw your pilot wearing
those John Denver glasses all right
there's a reason for that think about it
what am I talking about here can they
show that [ __ ] John Malkovich talking
to his phone and just having the time of
his life commercial one more [ __ ]
time what's more annoying that one or
where that weird family does the the
acapella version of Ozzy Osbourne's
crazy train with that random black kid
in the back like where did they get that
kid like you know is he an exchange
student and he just seems like he's over
all of it and not enjoying hanging out
with the other white people as he
[ __ ] shakes the ice in his in his
grape drink you know and then they got
to end that great song with the parents
singing like they're on Broadway you
know anybody else with me on that John
[ __ ] Malkovich sitting there all you
know if that if that commercial was 30
seconds longer he'd have the phone like
like blowing him tell me a joke do I
have anything coming up tonight now
lobster soufflé or whatever pretentious
[ __ ] foodie orders was a pretentious
bill are you just not cultured and his
order made you feel dumb all right you
got me on that one you got me on that
one
um I'm the only one who's creeped out
that there's a [ __ ] robot in my phone
or whatever it is it's that they try to
make it human what do they do that just
make it sound like a robot how can I
help you massage parlor Davidge I'm a
psychic power just do it like that so I
sit still keeps that like we keep that
distance I don't need intimacy with this
thing that isn't [ __ ] alive I don't
need that 2001 Space Odyssey experience
that's all I'm trying to say here people
oh he's Bill burr he's mad at phones get
out of his way everybody
this guy's got something to say what's
the deal with your average you ever
wonder if you're gonna stand the test of
time your decisions you know to me I had
a [ __ ] panic attack last night you
know turning 44 years old I just woke up
middle and night like Jesus Christ I'm
sliding into 50 you know and I don't
give a [ __ ] how well you take care of
yourself when you're 50 you [ __ ] look
50 unless you had some fat for your ass
blasted into your face and then you just
looked shiny but everybody knows you're
50 you're not fooling anybody with your
Real Housewife for forehead are you for
forehead eight head huh
is that show still on you know how long
have they got to keep doing that to
their clams are hanging out of their
bikinis isn't that Holly said I'm only
gonna do that one for let's try to beat
beat out the Drew Carey Show how many
[ __ ] episodes of that huh me years of
that [ __ ] show do they do
while people still didn't give a [ __ ]
the second they rolled in that fat lady
with the crazy makeup I mean right there
it's just like we're really not gonna
develop anything on this show are we
we're just gonna try to keep it uh just
kidding keep it whacky um ah jeez there
goes the phone hang on a second hang on
a [ __ ] second Christ's sake why don't
I shut the damn phone off who's this
who's this don't be my mom it's my dad
I just chose the podcast over my own
father who I owe I owe a huge apology to
I have a huge apology to my dad all
right
last night I was sitting on the couch
boo doodle-ooh do it mine and my own
[ __ ] business Loulou dude um I was
watching metal mania on vh1 metal mania
Cleo I think my dog is sleeping with
with its eyes open no no she just moved
her eyebrows dude where the [ __ ] did you
just go huh Cleo
whatever you thinking about it's gonna
be okay all right anyways you know it's
weird when my dog sees a squirrel
through a window it it cries like like
it's a long-lost buddy but if my dog is
outside and there's a squirrel you know
if there's no window between my dog and
the squirrel it will try and rip its
[ __ ] head off so I don't does anybody
know anything about dogs what is it
crying a buzzard crying oh I wish I
could just end that thing's [ __ ] life
you don't make any sense to me anyway so
I'm watching [ __ ] metal mania
alliteration this has got to be a hit
show right so I'm watching this [ __ ] and
at the risk of pissing off a lot of
listeners I think most metal slash hair
metal it arguably is the worst [ __ ]
music ever made worse than disco I don't
know why disco gets such a bad rap like
disco is is the default example of bad
music the way Hitler is the default
example of evil dude he's the next
Hitler it's always the next [ __ ]
Hitler never pull pot you know never
[ __ ] I don't know pickin up I don't
even know another one
you know Ivan the Terrible was that a
wrestler
was that a comic strip
I know horrible Haggar I don't [ __ ]
know right see I don't even I don't even
have any other examples whose fault is
that bill there's a library right down
the street everybody always talks about
disco and how bad disco was and they
just need to be a change man right and
like then they'll talk about like the
police and all this new wave [ __ ] and
the punk scene and all that but what
they they completely [ __ ] ignore is
that right after disco just immediately
the mainstream then went over to like
this [ __ ] heavy metal music like that
was better than disco I think it's
[ __ ] worse and I think all these
times will they keep saying that
everybody there was a big change and
that this quality music came out I don't
know if that happens I think it just you
know you know Nirvana comes around and
then what four years later everybody's
listening to [ __ ] oh Tom or the
mainstream is it's just this long tragic
just flat line of [ __ ] music I was
watchin the [ __ ] last night [ __ ] that I
used to like and my job was on the
ground how [ __ ] bad it was it was
horrible
III she I was so bad I was like texting
paragraphs to the sensation Joe DeRosa
Capitol Records the guy who built
Capitol Records Joe DeRosa I'll actually
you go I'll get a little intimate here
with you I'll read you the text message
I [ __ ] wrote Joe Joe hello
where the hell are we Joe hair slash
heavy metal is the worst music ever made
disco gets a bad rap watching metal
mania on vh1 Guns and Roses queens reich
wasp Quiet Riot David Lee Roth's solo
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] god-awful
yeah I saw David Lee Roth on on his Edom
and smile tour and I saw that video last
night going crazy
[Applause]
from the heat that sounds like a song
Wahlberg's character would have written
with john c reilly and Boogie Nights
remember that he will rock you oh you
like it was it was that bad teenage
Frankenstein I'm a teenage package dad
you're telling me that that song is
better than more than a woman more than
a woman more than a woman to be you know
I mean I think arguably it's I don't
know I can't believe this [ __ ] that I
used to watch and like I used to listen
to this [ __ ] around chicks you know just
hopelessly thinking that this would get
me laid like they would think that I was
some badass like loner bag boy
I mean the whole [ __ ] the fact that I
never got laid in high school it just
[ __ ] it went away right in that moment
it was like this is what I was gonna do
I wasn't gonna try to make him laugh I
wasn't gonna hit on him I wasn't gonna
try to I was just gonna play this music
around him and this was gonna bring me
to the [ __ ] promised land looking
like a [ __ ] teenager on Howard that
was my game plan is it any wonder I
failed Jesus Christ I remember I would
be watching it on a big square TV just
watch it lay it down
[ __ ] horrific [ __ ] music and my
dad would come in and just have his face
would just be all twisted up God Jesus
Christ what the [ __ ] you listening to
you like this [ __ ]
and I thought I was a rebel he doesn't
understand man
you know what he totally understand he
totally understood my dad called it back
in 83 called it jungle music so that's a
bunch of [ __ ] he told me straight up
okay man he was like son this music
you're listening to is [ __ ] horrible
and there was all this shout at the
devil is anybody really gonna sit there
and defend that [ __ ] song
do-do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do
you couldn't [ __ ] even [ __ ] a
five-year-old could write that on a
xylophone shout at the devil never knew
why we were shouting you know Blackie
Lawless Blackie Lawless that was his
show name and he took a radial arm saw
and he cut the blade in half and put one
hat one blade on one of his forearms
that one on the other on these leather
I'm gonna do a bunch of dishes in an
evil way gloves and we all thought he
was crazy it was just it he used to
throw [ __ ] raw meat into the crowd a
couple of them did that's why that Lady
Gaga covered her clam and that [ __ ]
pastrami it's just been done you know
comes out in that [ __ ] egg from Mork
I don't know I've seen the nasally
horror act my whole [ __ ] life you
know those [ __ ] chicks with the big
noses they can you know that's like
white people's answer to the big black
girl who can sing in church we tweet
what look the chick we bring to that
fight is the chit's the white chick with
the big nose white chicks with big noses
can sing I don't know what it is Barbra
Streisand it's all right I don't know it
it's like their nose is it's like that
dome at the top of all those concert
halls there you go bill try to spit it
out you dumb [ __ ] but I want some emails
people I want people try to tell me how
round and round Louisville by the way
give
damn maybe tell me the musical validity
that that has over like disco that all
those people probably at Comiskey plac
when they blew up those disco records
like [ __ ] five six years later that's
what they were listening to that was a
hit it was a hit in the eighties wow do
I owe my dad an apology i I just I was
sitting there just one video after in a
Queens Reich I mean all this stuff that
I thought was just [ __ ] unbelievable
you know what I'm gonna get emails this
week it's like I don't know what it's
gonna be it's gonna be like people
either gonna be like yes absolutely and
this is gonna be there's gonna be no
middle ground people thinkin a 100%
agree with me or I'm gonna get punched
in the face by Eddie trunk I just I was
taken aback I mean I haven't seen those
videos and [ __ ] forever occasion I'll
go back and I'll look at some old videos
but I mean a lot of it was like ac/dc
like [ __ ] they can like you know me back
in black is timeless there's some
timeless [ __ ] in there you know I even
watched that Guns and Roses sweet child
of mine I thought I thought it was
horrible and that little [ __ ]
shim-sham dance he was doing it's just
was oh and then the emotion he tried to
have in the end right and they kind of
closed his eyes like haha I really went
somewhere when I've just [ __ ]
horrible you know I was right - I like
helped hold it up Def Leppard pour some
sugar on me
I hated that when that [ __ ] came out
and all the ladies liked it and he came
out in his acid-washed jeans I actually
saw him on that tour
didn't I yeah Reynolds Coliseum and
Tesla opened up Tesla which I didn't
think they were that bed they weren't
that bed I don't know I thought you're
supposed to go back and listen to the
[ __ ] music of uh of your youth being
like wow that stuff was wrong that was
awesome man remember that and then you
know that was the first time I tried
blow you know reminiscent actually first
time I ever saw cocaine saw it and saw
it being done was at the Providence
Civic Center
I saw ac/dc on the who made who tour
with loudness the Japanese heavy metal
band that couldn't speak any English yet
sang in English I just can't imagine the
disconnect
I can't imagine like memorizing a bunch
of Japanese and going and over there and
just singing it and then not knowing
what the [ __ ] I was saying going out
there like I have no idea what I just
said
t-shirts of 20 bucks did I just say that
or did I say are you ready to rock I
have no [ __ ] idea anyways so I saw
them they opened up and anyways we're
out in the parking lot and we're
drinking beers thinking we're crazy
driving of course because it's the 80s
this is right around before right before
mad kicked in they used to bring like
wreckage from a fatal drug driving
accident anybody else is high school do
that they actually brought a car from a
fatal drunk driving accident and they
dragged it onto the lawn of our campus
you want to call it a campus a little
island with the tree they just left it
there and we all just stared at it
trying to figure out how many people in
the car how many people died and then we
just walked away like you know and
you're young you don't give a [ __ ] ten
minutes later you're talking about dude
I'm [ __ ] rap tonight Rhett that was
the word get rekt gets destroyed ham it
right so anyways we're driving down
there beer between your legs as you do
the eighties you know you [ __ ] lifted
weights all that week Neven all of it
above the waist curls [ __ ] benshan
shoulders
nobody did squats in the 80s nobody did
right so you got you [ __ ] tight 501
blues on with your little pencil [ __ ]
legs and then you over developed upper
body your stupid gold chain and you had
a beer between your legs that's how you
did it
so we're [ __ ] going down there were
probably on eight apiece [ __ ]
hammered I was driving this piece of
[ __ ] 83 Ford Ranger I got like five
[ __ ] drunk friends in the back which
was still not even grounds for getting
pulled over you could just have people
in the back like you were bringing
[ __ ] turkeys off to slaughter nobody
gave a [ __ ] right so we pull in and
right as I pulled up on it got a parking
spot there was this kid he had his door
open and he kind of like a Sammy Hagar
meets John Fogerty haircut blonde hair
and I remember he [ __ ] did a line
right as I was pulling up and I had
fortunately had my window up and he saw
me and he saw we all had ac/dc
t-shirts on or whatever and he just got
in the car was just it's like a haunted
house right up to the [ __ ] window and
I was just trying to take it all in like
okay he just how am I supposed to behave
around somebody with with who's on coke
does this guy have like you know Hulk
strength right now is he gonna tip over
the truck anyway so that was the friend
was the first time I saw blow I don't
know what the point of all that was I
was just shocked look I know it wasn't
all bad like this the early Metallica
you know right through and justice for
all I know that that stuff was great but
I'll tell you it is slim [ __ ]
pickings my friends
slim pickins I don't even I didn't know
what to tell you I mean I even go back
sometimes I try to listen to Appetite
for Destruction I know that's this this
watershed [ __ ] moment and that music
with some of those [ __ ] songs
they're out to get me so you can suck me
take that one too hard kill yourself
alright that doesn't get me a lot of
[ __ ] criticism let's you know what I
think it's time for some advertising
you're listening to the Monday morning
podcast by the way and this is my my
trip down memory lane the 1980s the
[ __ ] 80s
did I nail it though by the way everyone
had the 501 blues remember that button
fly dude I washed him three times and
you're nuts couldn't breathe you know
and you wonder why you got all these
[ __ ] crazy kids that need to be on
drugs now there you go mm-hmm hey
everybody Father's Day is next weekend
God knows I'm gonna get my dad a man
great guy trying to help me out 30
friggin years ago telling me that the
music I was listening to sucked and I
didn't even listen to him um
you got to act quickly on this one
seriously uh it's Monday all right
is there anything worse than when either
Mother's Day or Father's Day comes
around and you ran out of time and you
didn't get him a card you didn't get him
flowers you didn't get them you didn't
get him a damn man great why don't you
just take care of it today all right
just go on there slap it on your card
and he's gonna be psyched he's gonna be
psyched fathers days next weekend you
got to act quickly and get the perfect
Father's Day gift it's the man gay man
great grill enhancement system it's a
heavy-duty grill it's a hundred percent
married in America with cast-iron
grilling grates to upgrade any grill out
there on the market making you and your
family very happy Jesus they could have
got better copy on that one making
everybody happy instead of sad act now
and get the twenty dollar Monday morning
podcast special by clicking on the man
great banner on billboard comm all you
do is go to the podcast page you click
on the man great thing and every
Bilborough order comes with a heavy duty
man great grilling brush so for Father's
Day go to Bill Bird calm the podcast
page hit the button and take advantage
of our special $20 offer these things
are great instead of having like those
little wussy
you know like when you buy you your
grills you have like you know a little
skinny you have all the way from the
little hibachi ones that the Desai's the
the grill marks basically they're the
size of pretzel rods and then if you get
a halfway decent one you know they move
up to the the thick pretzel rods and
when you a kid you pretending like you
smoked a cigar would it be great if you
could just switch it out and just have
the same size ones you do when you go to
your favorite steak houses that's what
these guys are doing with the man grade
it's actually a genius system and it
kind of annoys me that I didn't think of
doing that it's the same like it's like
building a hot rod right you're
switching out the crap you got at the
factory to put on some high performance
stuff help your dad supercharge his
grill this Friday maybe I'll make you a
burger
you know and you guys can share an
awkward hug the man great everybody
$20 off there we go there we go that was
that was easy
that was easy advertising oh and by the
way I finally sent off a check to the
the Wounded Warriors Project so I can
stop feeling like a fraud I know I told
you I finally got a check in two weeks
ago but I've been so damn busy that I
couldn't take two seconds to click on
the internet to find where to send the
check and we gave him a nice check I
rounded it up to the next hundred
because I'm a good [ __ ] and I felt like
it did my good deed and if you're new to
my podcast you're wondering oh how can I
donate to this podcast and the Wounded
Warriors Project all is at the same time
just go to Bill burr com click on the
podcast page and and you'll see a banner
for Amazon all right if you're gonna buy
anything on amazon.com instead of just
going directly there just go to the
podcast page on my website click on the
banner and whatever you buy on there
they kick me a percentage and then I
take 10% of that give it to the Wounded
Warriors Project and now you can feel
good about yourself knowing that you
helped a group of people that truly
needed it and one jackass
who probably doesn't um all right all
right that started off good that start
off is a good read you know it's a good
read north at 3 o'clock I all right
let's get back to the the podcast
um all right what do we got here shoot
you know what I think it's time I think
it's time for a UH for a pyramid scheme
let's read this one hello mr. burr I
like that very formal a lot of respect
we did it out of respect we were wise
guys we did what we wanted I am writing
to you today because I need some help
about something recently my girlfriend's
father mother father separated thank God
we started reeling really annoying
everyone with calls emails and meeting
requests for some MLM multi-level
marketing aka pyramid schemes those
pyramid schemes [ __ ] little brother
all right your girlfriend's father
started really annoying everybody I'm
back on Pacey all right at first it was
please look at a DVD about a poor guy
becoming a rich guy by spending his time
building a water aqueduct instead of
wasting his time like the second guy
doing the hard work and carrying the
water on his back to the village plan
for the future they said or some other
[ __ ] of that sort there's been a few
other great and amazing business
opportunities that I could just delete
from my inbox but this time it's just
gone too far okay so first he gave you
the DVD then he's sending you some
emails and it was sort of yet whatever
you know use the DVD as a doorstop or
maybe to break up your weed and then you
just delete the email so so far he's not
being annoying let's move on to the
second that's the first ten pages of
this screenplay
alright let's move on to the action here
now he requires all of us to drop all
our phone internet providers to go with
his offer what I mean he requires you he
actually can't get anyone to go along
with that crap but as in every fable
he's got many pseudo facts about a big
thing that will come a big thing that
will make this company rich and then for
the small fee of $500 we can start
selling those great deals to how is this
[ __ ] legal by now he's contacting me
every day text message me emails
Facebook
comments all of that at first he was
nice now we started to use his skills on
me saying things like he's doing this
for me
and for his daughter's future I couldn't
believe he argued back when I told him I
believed it was not worth my time and
effort for the little monetary reward
good for you he said I was wrong not to
want to do it I mean my opinion is wrong
lol in any case if it was anybody else I
would take pleasure why can't I read
this week I mean I know I can't read
every week but this week I'm just really
just was it cuz I just had bacon is the
grease [ __ ] up my clogging up my
synapses here alright let's try this
bill striking a little momentum in any
case it was anybody else I would take
pleasure out of telling him to go [ __ ]
himself with his residual income and
that I am perfectly happy to be a
[ __ ] loser with the linear income he
taught me those terms yuck I want to
tell him that I would like to work by
the hour better than having to beg or
suck a dick in the back of a gas station
to sell a phone internet package that
will be worth a few points I already
have a great day job I work on my
photography I play PC games I jerk off a
lot too I have no time for this not that
I would even not that I would even if I
had the time I'm thinking of a good old
fading technique I learned in the past
love relationships but I'll always be
there at Christmas parties and such
pitching his [ __ ] please help me
before i strangle him thank you all
right what do you do here well you've
already done what I said what I was
gonna fake to say was basically say I'm
not interested why don't you make your
own DVD would he hand you a DVD of what
you should be invested in investing in
you just hand him a DVD of you going
thank you for your interest in making me
a millionaire unfortunately at this time
I am NOT interested please don't try
again later just to see how annoying he
is why don't you start spamming him now
that's gay
don't do that sorry I'm [ __ ] throwing
[ __ ] against the wall here what can you
do
why don't you just any time he starts
bringing it up just anything oh geez
just [ __ ] yell something why don't
you just go oh my god really loud and
walk out of the room every time he does
how about you get an air horn and any
time he brings it up just just right in
his face something I don't know what I
mean I don't I don't know you already
told the guy you're not interested I can
tell you what you don't do don't [ __ ]
about him to your girlfriend
alright he's his own separate annoying
entity and always keep it a joke between
you and your girl you know that's the
only way you could do it if you really
care about this girl and you wanna and
you want to stay with her if you don't
this is a great reason to [ __ ] dump
her but I mean I don't know what to tell
you
this is your girlfriend's dad and to be
honest with you if he wasn't doing this
[ __ ] he'd probably do something else
that would annoy you you know maybe this
is his passive-aggressive way of trying
to just ruin a part of your life because
he knows at the end of the day you're
[ __ ] his kid you ever think about
that once you stop being so selfish put
yourself in his position forsen is
annoying as his his you know
pyramid scheme is the end of the day
when you need your dick suck you're
going to this guy's daughter so you know
if you look at it that way I think that
you're winning all right all right bill
fathers here's another topic
what's with fathers having this the
standard ringtones
standard father's shoes and not giving a
[ __ ] what they wear for a hat
oh I can answer that despite the fact
that I'm not a father I know what that
is it's what I've been fighting my
entire adult life is having the woman in
your life just wear you down it's not
even that and then just the laws in
society it's what happens when you get
married as a guy is the
[Music]
the pilot light goes out for a lot of
things you just don't give a [ __ ]
anymore
you know I know you have kids he put
them first and all of that type of [ __ ]
but this it as much as it's from what
I've heard having a kid is the greatest
[ __ ] thing ever and I'm not making
fun of that but there is a part of you
that dies you know that howling at the
moon that [ __ ] you know going out I
just living it's just something this is
a part of life that just dies and you
just don't give a [ __ ] you're a beaten
man all right
you gave him the love you're married
there's no way out without just [ __ ]
having your wallet ripped out through
your balls and then back into your chest
cavity through your heart and through
your spinal cord you're [ __ ] you're
looking at a beaten man he doesn't give
a [ __ ] all I need is the phone to make a
noise you know and I can I know it's
ringing and I'll answer it I just need
these shoes to cover my feet so it
doesn't hurt if I step on a nail and I
don't get wet when it rains and I don't
give a [ __ ] I just don't want to get a
sunburn on top of my head I'll [ __ ]
wear whatever had you give me I don't
give a [ __ ] did you just don't give a
[ __ ] after a while I think that's what
it is
it's really sad actually when that part
of you dies you know what I mean
like I hit all that that midlife crisis
[ __ ] that people talk about that if
you're in your midlife you can't go out
and have a good time if you go out and
get hammered if you buy a cool car you
know if you haven't played guitar
forever and then you want to start
playing guitar again it's like you
trying to recapture your youth now I'm
trying to [ __ ] live I'm trying to
have something that excites me you can't
be excited beyond a certain [ __ ] age
when are you gonna grow up I think it's
time to grow up and if anybody says that
even if it's a woman you slap him right
in the [ __ ] face and say how dare you
that's how you get away with it cuz the
second the bouncer sees you slap a woman
in the face he's coming over there to
choke you out but if he hears the magic
phrase how dare you he stops in his
tracks
because he immediately knows that the
woman was completely out of line that
that works try it out this weekend
slap a woman in the face and and then
scream how dare you I guarantee you that
the physical way that you're removed
from that bar will be less than if you
just hauled off and slapped a woman
because haul off and slap a woman
you're an animal okay if you if you say
how dare you right afterwards you're
sort of the victim that theory has never
been tested if you're a faithful
listener I'd like you to try it out not
just randomly you know you got to find a
woman that deserves it in other words
stand in a bar for about eight minutes
don't don't do it
I do not Doug the slapping of women that
was actually to get me out of any legal
trouble and I said it in a funny voice
so then I'll get in trouble or weren't
you mocking or it wasn't that wasn't
even the warning part of the comedy mr.
burr now go [ __ ] yourself counselor I
think you supposed to win with those
Matlock suits all right to Rose's bio
the hell is this bill I was reading joe
de Rosas IMDB bio and it said something
like he did all these things despite the
fact that he was born without shoulders
is this a fact no that's actually people
who say Joe like that whole urban myth
that Joe DeRosa doesn't have shoulders
is like the same thing like that Mama
Cass from the Mamas and Papas died by
choking on a chicken bone you know
people just assume that that's why she
died cuz she was a fat chick but that
isn't how she she died of cardiac arrest
but the rumor started that she died
choking on a chicken bone and it stuck
like that gerbil up Richard Gere's ass
there's just some urban myths that just
never died they just have no facts
behind them that whole richard gere da
get a gerbil up his ass and it got stuck
or some shadow ran the wrong way [ __ ]
fell asleep in a rest area up his ass I
don't what the [ __ ] happened but you
know that like it's the stupidest thing
I've ever heard of my life and that was
just clearly started by somebody whose
girlfriend thought Richard Gere was
dreamy and he just walked into a bar
just said it I mean I don't know how
these [ __ ] things start Joe DeRosa
has shoulders if Joe DeRosa did not have
shoulders it would be impossible for him
to then you know he'd be missing his
shoulder joint he couldn't hold that
microphone in the the androgynous way
that he does the reality is what Joe is
missing is he's missing the meet between
his neck and his shoulders that's what
he's missing like it's a birth defect
Joe was actually born without collar
bumps if you which gives the the fact
that he doesn't have collarbones it
gives the illusion that he doesn't have
any shoulders and the reality is is
because his shoulders are where that I
don't know what you call it the shoulder
taint it's that meet between your neck
and your shoulders Joe was not born with
that unfortunately and an even sadder
there is no cure at this time but that
doesn't mean we're not going to stop
fighting and we're gonna have a benefit
we're just trying to get you know it's
hard to get all these guys you know get
everybody's schedules lined up but we're
definitely going to have you know some
sort of benefit to try and get Joe some
sort of prosthesis for you know plastic
collar bones alright I hope that clears
it up but I'm not trying to take away
the fact that he has accomplished
amazing things for a guy who has a
defective torso you know you ever think
about that I mean collar bones are a
bone that you really do take for granted
you know
he really is an inspiration that just
why he's the sensation you'd have to be
a sensation to achieve what he's done
with that awful body that awful hand
that God dealt him all right all right
so bill you've been you've been doing a
lot of activities you know when they say
what do you what do you buy the man who
has everything you know what you do you
get them activities my girl gets annoyed
at me because she goes I don't know what
to get you you buy anything that you
want you know I [ __ ] and I do and I
don't apologize for it if I want to play
hockey and you know I'll go buy some
skates goddamn it I got to sit around
and wait for you wait for a [ __ ]
birthday and a goddamn desert with
flames coming out of it before I get
what the [ __ ] I want all right
and the words of Bobby Brown I made this
money you didn't I'm [ __ ] buying it I
want to buy a guitar I'm gonna [ __ ]
buy it so she's I don't know what to get
you should I get you a shirt you know
what I'd rather you slap me in the
[ __ ] face don't ever get anybody a
shirt for a gun for birthday or
Christmas that that's the go [ __ ]
yourself gift here you go he's something
he's something that I could put paper
around you could you don't buy anybody
clothes how dare you so the lovely Nia
has been getting me you know just she
got me tickets to the John Bonham
birthday bash which was the [ __ ] oh that
was one a heavy metal video that I
[ __ ] loved and really it actually
stood the test of time was the second
album I liked the second Skid Row
Sebastian Sebastian Bach Sebastian
Sebastian Bach Vil or Sebastian back
Sebastian Bach they had a couple songs
on there that I liked it wasn't all bad
but I mean come on I was it was
shockingly bad you went from that awful
quiet right video to teenage
Frankenstein like I just was I couldn't
but I couldn't [ __ ] believe it
it was unbelievable
anyways so the lovely Nia yesterday she
took me horseback riding over in
Griffith Park and I said that why did I
say where we went because now I'm gonna
[ __ ] on it so we went over there I've
only ridden a horse once in my life and
the hard [ __ ] thing about riding a
horse when you've never ridden one or
taken any lessons is when they start
trotting is to stop your balls from
slamming off the [ __ ] saddle there's
a way you're supposed to ride with them
which of course they don't explain so I
was kind of you know that was like my
goal to learn how to ride a horse while
it trots without having my nuts slammed
you know back up into my body like I'm
freezing to death you guys are aware of
that right they get balls pull up into
you if it gets cold enough in a
desperate attempt to preserve heat down
there they pull up into you that's
that's that's what that term freezing
your balls off you know okay you know if
you stomp somebody long enough like they
will [ __ ] themselves which is the the
genesis of I beat the [ __ ] out of them
beat the piss out of them you know
that's the thing you about getting you
know if you got the [ __ ] beat out of you
you already got the piss beat out of you
because you know the piss gets beaten
out of you before the [ __ ] gets beat out
of you unless you're dehydrated alright
those those are the those are the
different levels of an ass-kicking so
anyways we go over to the stood this
this place to go to go horseback riding
and we go over there and there's at
least horses you know that you know if
you don't ride horse it's the first
thing whenever you see them aside the
fact that they're beautiful you like
that is a big [ __ ] animal and that
thing is a hundred percent muscle and if
that thing kicks me in my temple I am
gonna be drooling until the [ __ ]
until Jesus comes I'm gonna be done and
so anyway so we're feeding these things
you know with the English man teeth you
know really straight and yellow you know
holding your hand out like it's a plate
and they sitting there with
they're soft little muzzle eating the
carrot and that was all the good times
and then then we go to you know there's
all these good-looking horses now then
we go to like go to the horses that were
gonna ride and they're all back in this
pen and there's like [ __ ] twelve of
them may all have saddles on them and
they just got this look on that face you
don't I mean like you remember in
platoon when [ __ ] Charlie Sheen's
character just [ __ ] lands in the Nam
remember that and it's he's walking in
he's seeing all those [ __ ] troops
going home and he just sees that [ __ ]
looking if that's what those horses look
like and I felt like Charlie Sheen I was
waiting for one of the horses oh we got
ourselves a crusader here I did I felt
like the you know the little [ __ ] guy
going into prison I felt all these
things as I looked at those [ __ ] they
just had this vibe and so they pulled
two horses out one bigger than the other
and the [ __ ] in me is like I want the
smaller horse because I'm telling you
the second you get on a horse all you
think is Christopher Reeve [ __ ] lawn
dart right in the ground and then I have
my wheel myself out at some [ __ ]
benefit and act like I'm still enjoying
life [ __ ] that right I Drive myself
right off the end of the stage I'd go
right along with it get myself a tuxedo
oh yeah I mean things all good just
[ __ ] floor it with my tongue and I
dill myself right off hopefully hitting
a TV executive taking them out with me
that's how I would handle that challenge
in life because I'm a coward
so anyways I [ __ ] you know then I'm
like come on man you gotta let your girl
have the smaller horse so now they go
drag the bigger horse out this thing is
just [ __ ] like it's not rearing back
but it's making it really difficult the
thing is clearly communicating I don't
want to go and so I get on this [ __ ]
thing and the guy yeah you know you go
right you pull right to go left you pull
left and now you want to stop you just
pull it back all right so we start
riding the
things and they know the trail they're
just completely ignoring me and Nia you
want to go left they [ __ ] yank their
head back like go [ __ ] yourself we're
going this way I know I know the trail
alright they're [ __ ] well what's up
what's a word they use for some novice
cowboy what is that word
alright there huckleberry some of those
Western words hey what is worse hair
metal or some of that [ __ ] patriotic
country music post 9/11 what is worse to
you
what is more cringe-worthy you know
[Music]
shout at the devil or that that Toby
Keith Uncle Sam's gonna put a boot in
your ass every dime that guy made in
that song should've been thrown in his
face and then given to the troops or
something else or just and then the
partial of it would be to incinerate any
record that that that track was ever
recorded the most pandering horseshit
you could ever come out with horrific
sorry sorry plowing ahead here so
anyways like the horses were just in bad
moods they'll bitin at each other and
they just like at one point I try to
make the thing go left and went back and
I tried to bite my foot and I said then
they I go Jesus I go this [ __ ] thing
hates me and then I just thought I was
like you know what I'd hate me okay if I
climbed on my back and I had to walk me
up this goddamn hill I'd hate me then
somebody said that you know they don't
even feed him well over there I
shouldn't say that [ __ ] because I named
the place I don't know tried to claim
that they're over there their feed him
like [ __ ] shredded wheat instead of
the real stuff I have no idea but it
started off as this really peaceful
thing to be riding the horse which was
awesome and then immediately I just was
just like I couldn't get back soon
enough cuz I wanted to get off this
thing's [ __ ] back
because I knew that that's what the
horse wanted you know it's awful [ __ ]
just I think if I ever if I have a
[ __ ] at a ton of money I've said this
before if I ever got a horse I would buy
a horse just so I would never
I did so could have a you know maybe
once a week just to show him who's boss
all right you plant those carrots
they're [ __ ] Seabiscuit um anyways I
thought that was gonna be a funny story
and I'm just being a sad story kind of
like the Boston Celtics losing Game
seven oh that kills me that kills me
that those guys they're gonna break up
that team man I got to tell you I've
been you know I was I was lucky Celtic
fan when I grew up I started watching
and you know in sixth grade when Larry
Bird came through and all that [ __ ] the
battles with the 76ers the [ __ ]
Lakers and all that type of stuff and I
gotta tell you I am hard pressed to
think of another Celtic team that had
more heart than the Celtics this
dispersion of the Celtics you know they
just never quit never say said diet was
brutal watching Doc Rivers getting all
emotional when he hugged Kevin Garnett
was it was [ __ ] [ __ ] brutal brutal
but you know Miami Heat did that thing
and yeah I'm lovin that LeBron you know
LeBron is one of those guys that like I
was like I had what a douche bag when he
said I'm gonna bring my talents to South
Beach and all that but I got over it
after a while and then just people just
kept hating the guy and it's to the
point now I almost want to see him win
if I didn't like
Durant so much like either way I'm gonna
be really happy because I would love to
see LeBron get one just to make all
everybody who hates him unless you're
from Cleveland if you still hate LeBron
you're a douche bag you know you really
just hate some aspect he like but people
in Cleveland they should hate that guy
and New York and Chicago they should be
annoyed with that guy cuz he got you you
guys got you all excited like you know
Chicago six [ __ ] rings they have the
greatest player of all time Michael
Jordan okay they roll out the red carpet
for you and all you can come up with was
yeah I found their their offer
intriguing
intriguing like he was rubbing his
little uh you know I read books beard
that he's grown you know I'm into
alternative medicine half a goatee you
know if you grow a [ __ ] beard like
when bran has you better be like
inventing [ __ ] somewhere wearing some
sort of a lab coat all right and stop
putting on your fake black rimmed
glasses with the clear windshield you
got to hand it to black people they are
the only ones that who can make somebody
with a [ __ ] erector set look cool
they can somehow make that look
appealing I guess but I got to tell you
that NBA montage where they showed like
12 of them in a row all wearing those
glasses was [ __ ] ridiculous but
anyways
Chris Bosh killed us and all that type
of [ __ ] so I don't know I have no idea
but uh I don't know I thought that the
heat [ __ ] earned it that came out the
second half they [ __ ] and they just
never let up and we couldn't get back in
it and I don't know I don't know why the
[ __ ] we were trying to guard LeBron that
far out I mean even Van Gundy the whole
game was like just make the guy take a
jump shot you [ __ ] press up on the
guy he's too quick he's gonna run by you
once he gets to [ __ ] a step and a
half that freight trains coming you know
that first of all there's no way to get
in front of him quick enough to get a
charge you're gonna get hurt
all you can do is just try to hack at
the guy and he's gonna get fouled and
it's either gonna be two shots or an N
one so why not hang back I don't know
look at me watching [ __ ] the NBA for
a couple weeks all of a sudden I think I
can coach better than Doc Rivers but
anyways I'm going to Game six tomorrow
night because the [ __ ] Kings have
lost two in a row
for those you don't watch hockey man
they were up for Game three games to
none going to close out the fourth game
I went downtown got absolutely [ __ ]
hammered I planned on getting drunk I
did take this subway and but I also
planned on eating something went down
there on an empty stomach
and we found this [ __ ] bar that no
one was at that had this giant screen
and we were sitting there laughing lives
two minutes before the game there was
nobody in there felt like we were on MTV
Cribs we didn't have to pay for the
house and I don't know we had two drinks
we turned around on the place with
jam-packed and then I went to order food
and the guys like I'm sorry I'm not
serving food now because the stupid
manager didn't take into account that
the Kings could have won their first
Stanley Cup ever and that the sports bar
was gonna be packed so he just had one
guy working the bar so all he was doing
was making making drinks and you know me
I'm trying to watch my girlish figure
here so I [ __ ] after a couple beers I
switched over to crowns and I don't know
what happened I vaguely remember at the
end of the game going out and getting a
cheeseburger and the dude behind the
counter you know was a stand-up fan so
he knew me and my buddy and he gave us a
drink and then he actually brought over
some sort of like I never drink [ __ ]
like this he goes you should try these
out they're really good and it tasted
like a milkshake but it had it was like
a shot of it but it had booze in it I
just don't do well with that [ __ ] you
know I don't like that cross-pollinating
you know hey let's have a dessert and
get [ __ ] hammered I don't do that you
know let's go to a titty bar and get a
cheeseburger I don't do that either you
know the strip clubs that serve [ __ ]
food you know it's like do one or the
other
get one of these things focus need to be
streamlined all right so I'm trying to
be the best buy at titties right just
got absolutely [ __ ] and niibori ated
went down on the subway and the subway
it's almost like the red line in Boston
well one goes out to Braintree the other
one goes to Mattapan I was trying to go
to Braintree and I got on the Mattapan
one by accident I was like [ __ ] so I had
to get off hammered
took it back the other way and I go yeah
I want the Braintree one oh go
downstairs so I go downstairs and they
still have two trains running on that
track so I [ __ ] got on the Matapan
one again it was actually the Wilshire
one and
Oh God it was [ __ ] livid when I
realized I made a mistake I just looked
over at other passengers I was like it's
just [ __ ] thing going down Wilshire
and somebody looked at his buddies like
is he with you and everyone laughed at
me I was like out god I'm that guy then
I got off the platform the platform I
just had Tourette's [ __ ] goddamn
[ __ ] stupid ass [ __ ] City no
[ __ ] subway in the whole [ __ ]
countries I just absolute f-bomb and
then some really nice girl actually
talked to me like ignored my cursing and
my angry anger and spitting on the
tracks and was just like oh did you get
on the wrong way to my dad it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] she's just like yeah it is kind
of confused she didn't she didn't give
in to it she was a saint everybody
that's what I'm trying to say all right
last little round here of uh what do we
got here of advertising I got the last
one here Gamefly everybody my listeners
get a 15 day free trial with two games
mailed out in the trial new offer what
what did they just gave me bullet points
at this point do you think I have the
copy memorized see what do I remember
remember hey you guys like playing video
games don't you
would it be great if you had 8000 video
games at your fingertips what if they
could be delivered right to your
doorstep or your PC what if he got
15-day free trial
free trial come on you just broke up
with your girlfriend right how many
times you gonna lay there staring at the
ceiling wondering what the hell you just
did before you got to play a video game
and take your mind off of it well here's
eight thousand eight you can't break up
with with like a thousand chicks and
never think of any of them with eight
thousand games at your fingertips for a
15-day free trial you can't beat it
gamefly.com slash burr go in there click
on the microphone do what you got to do
get all those video games alright Cleo
will you stop licking your privates
please go off in the corner what are you
doing
it's [ __ ] weird you do it like every
[ __ ] 20 minutes you know do you need
to go to the doctor if you could see the
way this dog is just staring at me like
she actually understands what I'm saying
what's up buddy you know what you know
it's a great place to scratch your dog
is underneath the collar every once in a
while they wear the collar forever I
take my dog's collar off like every
night you know not because I'm a good
dog owner it's because she wakes up
before I do and she shakes like a madman
like this like that and it's basically
my alarm clock in the morning so I take
this [ __ ] thing off and then I give
her a nice scratch on the back of the
neck and she gets you know that look
dogs get on their face were they kind of
like it's this weird thing where they
don't move their body forward they just
move their face forward like that's what
it's doing right now you like that don't
you huh
that's what you can't get to all right
next scratch that's it that's what she
does with their [ __ ] ears and I know
it didn't sound that loud but it [ __ ]
6:00 in the morning
I'm sorry seven o'clock in the morning
it's real loud all right bill we've had
enough of your personal life hey Bill is
there any way you could bring the post
office into my apartment absolutely I
could
stamps.com everybody there's no reason
to go to the post office anymore okay
it's over like bell-bottoms it's done
all right this is just yet another thing
with today's technology you can just
actually handle while you're walking
around eating a bowl of Froot Loops if
you can do that with one hand and type
on a keyboard you go to stamps calm
everybody this is a great thing about
stamps calm not only will it save you
time you can buy and print official US
postage from your own computer or
printer okay slap it on an envelope they
give you a little they give you a little
scale you can weigh whatever the hell
are you trying to ship out it'll give
you the postage right on the meter you
slap that on there and you stick it out
in your mailbox it's done it's it's a
it's a complete circle all right stamps
come also will save you money it's a
fraction of the cost of
postage meter plus you get discounts you
can't even find at the post office what
more do these people need to do right
now if you use my last name Barbie URR
for this special offer you get a no risk
trial plus $110 bonus that includes a
digital scale and up to 55 dollars in
free postage alright don't wait go to
stamps calm before you do any click on
the radio microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in Burpee URR that
stamps comm enter B you are our do that
you know unless you enjoy going to the
post office maybe you're one of those
people maybe you like going down there
trying to find a place to park and all
the other things that go along with that
the homeless guy holding the door for
you thank you God bless thank you go up
place I could have done that myself
thank you thank you now you're the
martyr I know now I got to give you
money on the way out I get it I get it
or you could just be you know sitting
there in your jocks anyone else's dad
used to call your underwear your jocks
alright this podcast is getting too long
alright let's wrap it up here why don't
we go where did we go here what is this
oh this somebody reacting to last week's
that epic story that that bisexual kid
whose mom parents were really religious
and how they found out he was gay was he
was hooking up with a his some dude in
the house that she started whacking him
with the mail anyways this guy's Cybele
I heard the bisexual gay dude story you
told in your podcast most recently about
the guy who moved from the Carolinas to
Arizona for college and it got caught
doing the deed by his mom I am not gay I
do not have any gay tendencies or
anything like that
but I've seen a similar circumstance
happen with a close friend I know that
the dude's mom and the whole family
feels awkward about him being gay but
the more indifferent they act the more
likely the 19 year old guy from Carolina
will end up doing something he will
probably regret absolutely anyway my
advice is this show your mom the movie
prayers for Bobby and she will turn
right around
guarantee it hope things work out
alright I don't know what that movie is
but if the person who wrote in last week
go ahead and read that go watch that
movie or show it to your mom and
hopefully she'll come around
dilemma number one bill would you rather
have been born with the sporting talent
to be an NHL all-star or the musical
talent to drum for ac/dc after Phil Rudd
ah that's a good that as a [ __ ]
dilemma god dammit that's a coin flip
right there alright well here's the deal
if I could play in the NHL I play in the
80s despite the hair metal music that
would probably be being played while I
did the skate around in the beginning
that's to shoot around whatever the [ __ ]
you call it wait do I have my body I
mean I want to be a tough guy if I'm
gonna play in the NHL I'm like we I have
a a the very best a goalscorers body and
even then I'm too small I'm barely 5
foot 10 guys could do that back then
could I be it if I could be chippy every
once in a while Nevin mark what style I
don't know know the musical talent to
drum for ac/dc after Phil Rudd well if I
drummed for ac/dc after Phil Rudd I'd be
Simon right from 83 to 90 then I would
leave to Joan do and have to play last
in line or I could have been considering
I'm balding maybe I'd be Chris Slade who
drums from 90 to 96 and all of a sudden
gets kicked out just cuz they want to
bring Phil Rudd back I don't like those
endings those are like running back
careers
those are real short you know what I'll
take the NHL all-star a [ __ ] all-star
and I get to wear either that Campbell's
or Wales Jersey oh I take that have a
[ __ ] red mullet
I'm here to gets curly when it grows
long I'd look like Bernie from room 222
I take the NH
that was a good one it was the old coin
flip alright number two dilemma imagine
you're walking in a built-up area and
come across a glittery box what is a
built-up area curiosity compels you to
look inside it and upon doing so find it
stacked full of child pornography
your prints and DNA are on the box so
you can't walk away from it if you set
it on fire what happens if the cops stop
if a cop stops you or residents and they
notice a half-charred picture of an
eight-year-old
he's burning evidence if you hand it in
to the complete the police you'd still
be implicated no I wouldn't
if I find a [ __ ] dead body on the
side of the road I don't get charged
with murder quick light it on fire
this is hilarious anyway let me just
keep reading this I'd be implicated as a
suspect because I found a ten of child
pornography and I brought it in they
probably give me [ __ ] for contaminating
the evidence that would look weird
though if I walked in I kind of see
where you're going with this uh you just
would oh you just say no matter what you
just would get implicated and I think
you could do without headlines like
comedian hands child porn into police
claims I found it and he's misunderstood
like Michael Jackson if you decide to
take it home to destroy it what if you
stop by a gang of yous on the way and
it's knocked out of your hand and the
entire Detroit depraved mass spills
across the floor if you don't get it
home and turn it into a paper mache in
the sink what if you do get it home and
it turns into paper mache in the sink
what if it blocks it or Nia asked what
you're up to nothing they're just
destroying images of naked preteens
so how would you deal with this terrible
situation simple curiosity compels me to
look at the glittery box I would open it
and upon seeing the contents within I
would jump back like Morgan Freeman's
character and
seven when he sees Gwyneth Paltrow's
severed head in the box all right and
then I would just start running in
circles yelling he has the upper hand
until I'm arrested and put in an insane
asylum I just if I found I would just I
would report it immediately I would
report it immediately you know that's it
I saw it I opened it it was in there and
that's it go ahead parade a bunch of
half-naked kids in front of me and watch
me not get aroused there you go there's
my [ __ ] defense go [ __ ] yourself I'm
trying to help you guys out
why don't you dust it and find the other
set of prints and go start with that
douche all right now me and my [ __ ]
looking dog are getting out of here go
[ __ ] yourselves all right lights camera
dumped bill I'm a 29 year old guy and
recently broke up with a funny
attractive and all-around great girl oh
geez
why sir would you do that you asked all
right um two things
her dad was born without teeth in your
word your baby will if you breed with
her or she has got something going on in
a vaginal area some sort of odor stinky
[ __ ] I don't know well here we go well
let me tell you this girl and I have
been dating for about three months and
we had a great thing going she's half
afro-cuban half Puerto Rican and really
sexy she had a rough upbringing but I
didn't care because she's honest
easygoing and not [ __ ] like so many
girls I've dated she was a bit needy but
I didn't mind we were out at a bar one
night having a few drinks and I was
feeling pretty good I was looking at a
couple of flus he's at the end of the
bar and I asked her if she's ever been
with another woman she coyly looked at
me and said yes good stuff I thought
yeah dude this is a [ __ ] fantasy
right here if I can red Shoe Diaries
then I proceeded with have you ever been
in a threesome with two girls and a guy
again she answered yes okay kind of
[ __ ] but I'm no
well he couldn't stop there oh god
you're gonna go for the rotisserie
question oh here we go here we go strap
yourselves in for this one well I
couldn't stop there so I asked have you
ever had a threesome with two guys she
looked down at the ground and she looked
up a bit ashamed Lee and said yes Wow
skank alert I thought I then asked her
one more question I knew this one could
back from where the [ __ ] do you go from
here like throwing the high heat to
Albert Albert pool host I finally asked
wait have you ever been in a porn
she then blushed and looked me in the
eye and said yeah
I looked at her calmly and was like oh
but inside I was like jesus [ __ ]
christ yeah as well you should you know
those first couple I mean you can look
at let's break this down here all right
she's been with uh she's had a threesome
with another girl and a guy who get that
that's who gives a [ __ ] right there all
right you already knew she banged
another guy all right but the fact that
she also did it with another girl that
takes a little [ __ ] that tones down
his dick in her [ __ ] right this is how
guys think women I'm sorry all right
that's something that that's something
in the the credit is that the credit
bill why do you try to talk accounting
[ __ ] you're too dumb all right that
one's alright the two guys thing now you
can look the other way on that maybe if
it was in another state but it can't be
in the same state because if you run
into one of the two guys that [ __ ]
you know we're high-fiving as they
[ __ ] banker that I mean I don't know
about that one but then the third one
she did a porno I mean yeah no that's uh
you got to walk away from that or or you
have to go to NASA to get tested for the
latest [ __ ] STDs
I would think and then also God knows
what's going on mentally that you would
do that what I just like sex no no no
there's something going on who doesn't
like sex I don't know
anyways plowing ahead see so she goes so
basically she had moved down to Los
Angeles when she was 20
she's now 25 and after a short stint in
the military somehow she got into the
porn industry for 8 months
she did everything ooh [ __ ] sucked the
whole shebang I asked her if I could see
her video but she wouldn't tell me her
performer name and said Viet Minh Lee
that it would be impossible to find her
body of work I asked her why she got
into porn and she replies because I
wanted some feeling in my life and then
he writes doji's yeah dude
this poor girl something happened to her
the thing was she was clean had a good
job and I really liked her and the sex
was great yeah obviously you know what's
funny there was something you wrote in
the beginning where I just thought she
was gonna be good
twenty-nine-year-old guy attractive
all-around great girl oh the fact that
you said she had a rough brain
upbringing but she was easygoing and
honest and not [ __ ] right that was
like that girls couldn't bed that just
seemed like a kind of free open person I
don't know I didn't know she was gonna
be that open anyways the thing was she
was clean and I'm a blonde the sex was
great but I couldn't stop picturing her
in some sleazy porno that was probably
filmed in some junkyard on La Brea so I
went to ask for a friend's advice most
of my guys were telling me to dump her
my gay friends told me it was fabulous
and that I should overlook it I didn't
even bother asking my girlfriends
because they would automatically reject
her and assumed I had AIDS there you go
keep your options open so regretfully I
dumped her I felt terrible and obviously
didn't tell her it was because she was a
porn star because she would have been
ashamed for the rest of her life and I
was happy that she was
honest with me I've done my fair share
of sleaze but this was too much my
question bill was bill my question bill
was it wrong for me to dump him for some
decision she made years ago should I
have stayed with her what would have you
done well you don't want to know what I
would have done I'm a [ __ ] degenerate
so lets you you seem like a good person
dude when you're trying to find the
person you're gonna spend the rest of
your life with you have to have a list
of criteria
all right you sound like you're still
young so there's no reason to compromise
all right I mean when you get with
somebody like that and you're gonna live
with them and you get with anybody
you're taking on all of their [ __ ]
baggage all right you're only three
months in and you know people who go
into the poorness industry that you know
it's like people become comedians we're
not healthy individuals okay and that is
like a specific area that I just this is
just my own personal non-medical feeling
that you're just not a healthy person
something awful happened in that line I
just wanted to feel something I mean
something bad happened to her caused her
to wall herself off I don't even want to
try to guess what but you know there's
nothing wrong with anything that she did
personally don't technically and she was
honest with it it all comes down to
whether or not you want to deal with it
all right and if you feel that you know
you want to deal with it and that there
was this sort of connection that you
just had this girl had to be in your
life then you're gonna have to learn to
live with it and get past it but I would
be definitely I would definitely be
concerned with certain mental issues not
only she's insane and then I would also
be concerned with sexual boundaries you
know
like would she have any and could she
remain faithful after a while and when
you settle into the seven-year itch or
whatever and you really start needing to
work at the relationship and it's
feeling boring and she needs to feel
something again is she gonna go back to
that leather couch from that show
Martin MA in you know down on fugg in
the valley and get banged again I mean I
don't know I don't know that is a that
is you know what that is beyond my
skills I don't know how to tame that
horse I could tell you that right
[ __ ] now I don't I have no [ __ ]
clue that's a you know what that's a dr.
Drew question that is a a classic dr.
Drew question and that guy within two
seconds will get right to the core of it
I would call I'll call in Loveline men
if you're out here call him up because
that's a that's a great one
[Music]
yeah I guess you'd have to figure out is
has she worked through whatever the [ __ ]
she was working through and now she's
ready to I mean I don't know hey those
are some good-looking girls down there
and she's like yeah they are or whatever
like I mean if you kept staring and in
that direction
you'd probably get you [ __ ] threesome
right there so there's that there's that
option the option that you have is if
you're with her like I think you mean
that's that's a selfish [ __ ]
na-na a shallow reason to stay with
somebody long-term that Jesus I don't
know great [ __ ] emails by the way
everybody open and piss you guys off too
much by [ __ ] trash and all that metal
[ __ ] you know I have half those t-shirts
and I went to go see that I was just
embarrassed by some of that [ __ ] that I
used to listen to Jesus right up until I
was like twenty twenty-one [ __ ]
brutal what redeemable thing that I have
I did listen to The Beatles The Doors
the stones all that white boys [ __ ]
Stevie Ray Vaughan I did listen to
Hendrix I listened to all the big bands
swing through my dad shift from the 50s
I had such a weird musical upbringing
anyways which was actually good because
it was kind of all over the map I
started hanging out with Patrice back in
the day Patrice was the one rest his
soul got me the I still remember when he
got in the same piece-of-shit truck that
I went to the ac/dc concert and seven
[ __ ] years later I'm still driving it
right making the sacrifices remember
that I told you you don't get some
[ __ ] job and go out and buy a [ __ ]
new car you just change yourself to your
cubicle I always kept Mike I put a new
engine in the [ __ ] truck had somebody
slap that in there for 1,200 bucks pay
that down rather than 12 grand for a new
car like it was back then so anyways I
still remember swinging by picking
Patrice up and going into NICs and he
had the cassette tape of Ray ready to
die and him putting that in telling me
that this guy was going to be the next
guy and then through all of that
like he cured me of all the rap that a
white kid liked who lived in a
cul-de-sac and he showed me all all of
that [ __ ] so I had that whole background
all that stuff [ __ ] held up but the
[ __ ] metal that I listened to I even
watch like Lawrence Welk when I was a
kid when the creepiest shows ever even
that was [ __ ] thrown in there it's
funny like [ __ ] almost 40 years later
I'll be walking down the street and all
of a sudden Winchester Cathedral will be
going through my head
Winchester Cathedral buh doo doo doo doo
he'll bringing me down am I really gonna
sing this you could have done something
[Music]
let's wrap this up
upcoming shows I'm gonna be at the
improv in San Jose June 14th and 15th
this weekend Sacramento zone chelsea
peretti is not going to be there
unfortunately so I replaced her okay
like that chick on that [ __ ] show
with
sandy Duncan Kevin shake
Kevin Shay's gonna be there was [ __ ]
hilarious really original so it's gonna
be an awesome show San Jose June 14th
and 15th at the Improv Theater in
downtown San Jose on June 17th I'll be
at the Chicago theater part of the Vince
Vaughn Wild West comedy show with Steve
Byrne Vince Vaughn and a bunch of other
guys it's gonna be an amazing show that
might already be sold out that's June
17th so if it isn't it's gonna be go to
billboard calm and you know click on all
these ticket links real quick the
Ontario Improv June 29th 30th and July
1st the Inland Empire then it'll be
going out in the Boston area dude
Hampton Beach ballroom casino Hampton
Beach [ __ ] New Hampshire July 14th
and after that I'm going down to Rhode
Island Kidd going down to the Newport
yachting Center July 15th I'll be in a
tent out in the parking lot come on down
there'll be a good time and that's it
that's it that's the podcast for this
week thank you for listening I'm gonna
miss those Celtics goddamnit I'm gonna
miss a hell of a run
and it still kills me that fourth
quarter of the 2009 finals I really wish
the refs had gotten out of the way and
if the Celtics were gonna lose I could
have watched the Lakers you know win
that you know not taking 24 unguarded
shots it's just [ __ ] kid it's not the
Lakers fault I just read the [ __ ]
refs
they just they have too much goddamn
power too much [ __ ] power man put
your [ __ ] whistle away alright that's
it go [ __ ] yourselves I'll talk to you
next week
you